é obrigado por esta apresentação que era
bairro meu deus expectativas aqui em
altas é tão obrigado por ter vindo hoje
aqui e passar esse trecho o caso erenice
também atende por braga como convidado
em particular o novo a8 resistência que
conseguiu é quebrar a minha é minha é a
minha menina e fininho a teimosia e
portanto é castro eu para falar um pouco
vago no meu percurso profissional e
daquilo que tem sido nos últimos anos
nos últimos anos da minha deste trecho
do percurso na área digital no
julgamento e não podia começar sem
explicar como é que existe aí
e porque todas estas coisas aconteceram
é e ele quer dizer quando sair a hora
que sai bastante cedo mas bastante de
trabalhar mais cedo que varia de 35 anos
meu primeiro trabalho foi em 1991 1992 é
foi um dia bastante bastante gostoso
apesar do trabalho sempre que seja
realista da vida nunca aqui será nem
bombeiros nem polícia nem a essas coisas
que sempre se o jornalismo e foi pra
isso lá no 91 92 que tive o meu primeiro
trabalho em que meu pai me podia
trabalhar é e há um registro único
registo e eu vou passar aqui que só
assim durante o segundo set wozniacki
depois aparece uma história imaginária e
desaparece ao cair que é só para ver o
que o facto foi foi foi moroso e fizeram
mestras esta fizeram passar por isto é
uma cultura é jornalístico foto
jornalística no prêmio professor da fia
o fotojornalista que digamos num dia de
fevereiro ou no mês de março
e é isto
é no dia de carnaval é eu quis machucar
jornalista então foi isso que meu pai
meu jogo e meu pai sempre gostou muito
de fotografia e como na altura se
grafava com hall já é e com inúmeras
máquinas porque nem tinha as lentes da
manhã em frente à r via que os coletes
grandes muito vocês que ainda se
recordam dizeram colocado jogou
fotográficos e depois é se utilizar anos
atrás das diferentes máquinas
eu vi um chapéu do correio da manhã
enfim um colete porque achava que o
fotojornalista que era aquilo que eu
queria ser importantes no meu irmão mais
novo os alunos tiro em mim está ótimo
já chega tá bom vamos tirar o importante
é que a equipe se mantém na brincadeira
naturalmente mas é mas eu sempre que
sejam sempre quis ir à área de
comunicação é evando lisboa eo 20 ontem
porque felizmente tive a sorte virou
norte que gosta muito de ficar porque eu
também sou viseu também sou que não
nunca longe bateu quando fui para
desgostar fui logo para esses a conexão
emília continua ser jornalismo e é o na
altura não acho que foi no terceiro ano
fui competente de jornalismo estava
cansadíssimo apenas na popular porque é
uma coisa que não estava a começar a
acontecer
e desculpa mas esse dado mas eu
precisava trabalhar para criar um novo
desafio para mim para minha vida pensei
para mim é que eu vou ganhar dinheiro é
ter uma vida boa para se criar uma
pensadora minha volta de uma série de
amigos meus que trabalhavam na etapa
decisiva nem mais
vou continuar a gastar e vou tratar você
começar embora bastante estou já
prepararam planetas em entrevista por
uma gravata enfrentam espanha na casa de
banho perfeitamente eu comento fone
estava o lado e
e tendo uma inovação para o thiago neves
aprovou o trabalho no youtube
para santos a procura de uma pessoa para
para entrar na nossa equipa de produção
da valentim de carvalho
temos aí estamos a criar a começar a
produzir um novo programa para tv e
portanto acho que esse plano é promover
a nba e twitter entrevistas fato isto
basicamente nunca mais de lá que quer
fazer e pensar olha vamos embora disse
nada acho que tem muito mais a ver com a
área que eu queria que eu queria dizer
que eu queria para mim do que
propriamente essa é a decisão que na
altura estava estava tomada e portanto é
isso aí
a fia entrevista fiquei começar
imediatamente no dia seguinte e fui
consumida na produção de conteúdos é e
consegue na produção de conteúdo para a
área de televisão
estive a trabalhar em televisão criei no
programa certamente vocês lembram é é
nosso trabalho eu passei pelo levante
intervalo o luisão para ser morta se
você viver
nós trabalhávamos com diferentes canais
sic tvi e rtp
enfim uma série de coisas do destino ao
que o que o objetivo é trabalhar em
televisão e os conteúdos porque os
conteúdos televisivos de uma via uma
capacidade e possibilidade de prever e
mais tarde em 2010 nós aqui estamos em
2007 quando comecei a trabalhar é indo
já em 2010 que o siv pra mim porque o
tamanho foi na altura que que fui pai no
início e que utiliza trabalhava como o
projeto existe um projeto três meses e
para não fazer para três meses só que
esse temos que o vídeo foi lançado
muitos lembram que andando pelo projeto
o projeto estava pensado nisso e cria
cria qualquer coisa mais fixa e mais que
um beijaço também organizar a minha vida
e então se viu cair esta que eu vou
trabalhar para conexão mais à séria e
procurar aí uma agência ansa
não sei procurar trabalho e esses dias
vi alguém enviar o currículo e fui parar
tive a sorte de parar a a torta 2.0 2.0
não sei se alguma vez ouviu falar dos
atores por dizer foi a primeira agência
olhar apenas social media em portugal é
tratado por 10 criou ainda estratégias é
é na altura do iff temos aqui temos aqui
falar de alguns anos de alguns anos
atrás
em 2010 entre o motor 3.0 porque o toque
um grande cliente o importante era fugir
canais fox um dos canais fox tem o canal
fox fox
o fox life tenho national geographic tem
o fx tem essas coisas todas
e nós na altura estávamos a trabalhar
toda a conta dos canais fox
estive a trabalhar durante nove meses e
uma vez viu apenas uma vez por semana
ela só assim apenas uma vez por semana
na nossa agência estive diretamente nos
canais fox durante todos esses nove
meses a tomar conta das vezes redes
sociais e de toda a estratégia existe em
torno das duas redes sociais dos canais
fox é não contente e sempre vamos vamos
vamos vamos diz que quer aquilo que é
mais do que isto já que há nove meses o
volume de dados e os entrará como
acautelatório 2.0 e foi o que eu fiz só
que agora eu quero vender agora quer
desenvolver propostas
agora quero ir o cliente que era o quero
quero quero eu próprio ajudar a trazer
clientes para para para a agência que eu
fiz mas tenho que mostrar resultados
rapidamente levar muita gente certamente
está na área das vezes nós corremos em
viaturas contactos que temos de ganhar e
eu não trazemos claro que o estado tem
estado a trabalhar em televisão
tendo isso trabalhar conteúdos de
televisão para a fox não faz nada claro
então naturalmente contactar os os
produtores é impossível trabalhar antes
de trabalhar conta também os canais e
fui buscar na altura para contratar
responderam
é um molde a que todos conhecerão
certamente não foi a produtora
responsável pelo bigode por exemplo em
2006 e os banheiros na altura cup time
que eu fui buscar um modo como cliente
para parar 3.0 e tamanho teve e tivemos
sorte
o prazer de poder desenvolver na
primeira grande estratégia para para
programas de televisão é nossa nós
esqueça o conteúdo em si o programa em
si porque como sabem se os programas são
problemas de muita audiência é que se
consegue trazer muita publicidade se
consegue desenvolver só sem desenvolver
grandes equipas para entorno leitor
neste projeto
o primeiro programa foi o ciclo de sorín
nosso ciclo histórico que vivemos é uma
equipe de mesma equipe de dez pessoas
estavam em turnos de 24 sobre 24 horas e
na altura isto é uma loucura
estabilidade da equipa mini preço é esta
que enfim as coisas acabaram por correr
bastante bem e arranjarmos uma pequena
sabrina venda do pinheiro onde montar o
nosso nosso escritório é e montar e toda
a equipa e tivemos durante quatro meses
e praticamente vivendo na venda do
pinheiro vão trabalhar nos 24 24 horas
em turnos atualmente no entanto foi um
desafio bastante interessante porque não
havia histórico não havia histórico nada
na história que o programa de televisão
desde desse tamanho desta dimensão e
dessa importância é a ser trabalhadas em
redes sociais
foi um projeto muito interessante de ser
desenvolvido é mais tarde claro que fico
com isto que capture paraná recebeu
toque
fui como consultor para o departamento
de marketing de tv onde é que vai também
por desenvolver algumas estratégias para
uma série de programas de onde iniciamos
por exemplo é a casa fosse falar esta
quinta feira não foi nesse grande
exatamente agora desenvolver a primeira
página do facebook
as primeiras páginas de facebook eo
então alguns programas na altura em que
se viu foi a mulher mais gostosa
hoje pelo próprio por levantar de uma
série de outros programas para jantar no
domingo 27 e fica em um percurso durante
um animal e talvez como consultor de tv
em que temos várias equipas
aí eu estava não sabem empresa nenhuma
está aí o próprio passavam os recibos
verdes em várias equipas de vários
programas que dá uma loucura é
chatíssimo continuar assim
volta então para agência e leve toda a
equipe todos os projetos por lá
e aqui um ponto de viragem mais uma
existo e um quarto foi bastante
interessante tanto né minha no início do
percurso como parece me no panorama
nacional de tóquio a atmosfera e os
influenciadores é tudo começar bastante
bastante mais tempo é certo mas o que um
projeto que nós já vamos lançar que foi
o da lectina o love da cantora o que
significará que vai fax trazer maior
audiência e o maior número de olhos
postos em cima de tudo tudo que envolve
as férias tudo que influenciou outros
são influências e comunicados nas redes
sociais
e nós temos a sorte de fazer em 2013
lembrou na altura que as exigências mais
ligavam a perguntar como é que como é
que nós podemos fazer e como elas podem
estar aí é comum em vídeo e fotografias
isso josé francisco sá carneiro como
isso acontece
havia sim uma uma grandes questões é em
torno disso e nós fomos gravando caminho
fomos mostrando o fundo dependendo do
projeto fomos mostrando como é que as
coisas podiam ser feitas e depois mais
tarde lançaram de um outros bons rapazes
em que também participe com com 1 mil
pedro teixeira
nós precisávamos temos um bom projeto
para atingir o segmento feminino
fizemos também um bom projeto para
atingir o segmento masculino e aqui o
grande nossa grande grande arma foi o
facto de conseguirmos é trabalhar vêm as
marcas de uma forma bastante consistente
tanto uma como outra e nunca fugir muito
daquilo que era o nosso plano inicial
nós criamos do por um lado ana cristina
ensinar a ensinar ex time todo o projeto
em torno de moda e vai estar anunciando
o universo feminino estava em outro
projeto para o universo masculino e
fizemos fizemos isso com rapazes eo mec
é que os homens gostam de estado nós
vamos estar juntos das motos dos
dos carros possam ver viagens de
aventura e esse tipo de coisas acabaram
puro por por nos ajudar a desenvolver
então foi depois desta necessidade de
lançar os projetos que criamos então
leve leve neste momento com seu puro 9
em digital piar exatamente love no blog
de topiary pessoa passado criar um ano
anima e leva em conta em digital pior
porque também nos apercebemos com
conhecer que não se trata apenas do blog
trata sim de conteúdo e tudo isto é em
torno do conteúdo e importância do
conteúdo
mas tanto de nós aqui somos diariamente
com produtores de conteúdos nos façamos
isso não fará um profissional como fiel
fazemos isso nos nossos dias no nosso
dia a dia para a família nem que seja
através do whatsapp nós estamos com
constantemente criar conteúdo e
tratava-se continua e nós mudamos o nome
da agência para lá enquanto digitam piar
e passamos a assumir o gerenciamento em
ambiente digital de uma série de figuras
públicas e que no fundo aquilo que nós
fazemos hoje e acrescentava o nosso o
nosso portfolio de vice disse também que
a estratégia para as marcas junto com
influência da soja de nós trabalhamos
não só não só gerencial e nós também
desenvolvemos estratégia para as marcas
é e procuramos os influenciadores no
mercado que que julga e clã
corresponderia o briefing que foi
passado é esse é o nosso trabalho hoje
em dia e portanto enfim nós sabemos
também uma série de projetos mas a
importância do conteúdo é muito grande
quando vai em ter connosco para e já
foram dezenas de instituições em que há
eu quero te quero dizer que revoga quer
fazer um projeto para quem quer fazer um
bom time
então um saque que gosta de fazer sexo
só visto
ah ah ah ah eu vou perguntar mas será
cozinhas fotógrafas cortes faz maquiagem
sei lá qualquer coisa a fátima vai
pensar nisso depois volta cá porque
porque não existe verdade no conteúdo
que criavam vai ser muito mais difícil
desenvolvemos os projetos e ouvimos os
conteúdos e nunca é muito mais difícil
este projeto crescer e se desenvolver em
itu isto é autónomo basco num nós
apostamos sempre em projetos e com em
pessoas que os lucros nos jogos em que
existe este potencial e esta força
vontade e esta verdade no conteúdo e
isso é fundamental
há 15 dias o time conquiste né na rússia
e no dia de um fórum que era o feche
nenê economics z8 e o tema dela para
para este fórum foi precisamente a
verdade é verdade que se passa lá pra
casa né partir da criação do conteúdo
e tudo isto é fundamental é fundamental
que seja seja passado de forma
verdadeira mesmo aqui também eu posso
dizer o que nós neste momento nesta fase
estamos a já que vamos podíamos sair o
produto que era importante é que é
importante temos para parece que estamos
temos um mercado e nesta fase
achamos que precisamos achávamos
precisávamos mais qualquer coisa para
entregarmos todos estes conteúdos forma
de três vitórias para conseguirmos
comunicar de forma bastante de forma
diferente e consegue cativar as pessoas
estão lá em casa também ou entregar as
fotografias os vídeos e todo o conteúdo
que os vêem seja em sites e blogs seja
mesmo na televisão a entregar tudo isso
de forma diferente
fizemos uma parceria com uma com uma
tecnologia
passamos a representar em portugal essa
mesma tecnologia e essa aplicação e no
futuro muito próximo
tudo que já se fala há bastantes anos
que os tucanos crime existe existe há
séculos 15 step possível nós estamos a
fazer uma série de coisas que têm a ver
directamente com com os problemas de
lesão mas vai ser possível este existe
mas de uma forma ainda mais integrada em
ainda mais dinâmica ponto
não tarda o nós vamos poder inteiro
conhece já sabe com certeza nós vamos
poder ter o shazam de televisão é ouvir
o programa que estava a área e uma
novela parece qual devia por exemplo e
tudo que estava claudia está a vestir ou
mesmo já está na cidade de braga por
exemplo toda aquela informação vai
aparecer no player no lateral dodô voz
telemóvel ao vosso computador ou do
vosso tava e toda essa informação está
disponível está disponível para seja
para comprar seja para para visionar a
seja o que for e portanto está tudo
muito interessante porque também é o
futuro física também este destes dias
fiz por exemplo tem pontinhos com
informação de cada uma das coisas que
nós queremos fazer sobressair e
partilhei é possível através de apenas
mais 12 clique
nós temos conseguindo ter todos os
produtos em casa ou então nós temos a
informação e portanto a única coisa que
eu queria passar ao longo deste mês já
passei tudo que eu pensava que não ia
ter um assunto falado aos 18 minutos
a única coisa que eu queria passar e que
ninguém aqui é importante passar aqui né
se há aqui alguém que quer ser o criador
de conteúdos egito essa gente segurança
jean enfim o que quer que seja
pensando nesse projeto e pensa é e qual
é a vossa verdade qual é que o vosso
entusiasmo que a gente já ajudou a criar
qualquer conteúdo que vocês poderiam
trazer mais valias e acrescentar
realmente um boom
valorizar e portanto esse é importante
que poderá trazer trazer essa verdade
parece a criação de conteúdo e e aqui
também um lado neste lado esquerdo
empreendedor quando estou nos cuscuz os
projetos chegarem à frente avalia os
riscos desse mesmo projeto
mas eu diria que depois do programa aos
riscos e exige terem certeza que podem
arriscar e podem avançar
vendo que o tema terex não diga eu não
digo que não nunca diga nunca e vannuchi
ão e e sigam com com força com convicção
e em e portanto acho que também portanto
por uma paixão pegar uns e por uns
tamanho amor não é nem aquilo tudo
aquilo que fazemos tudo como eu vou
terminar este esta este festa top mas
este tamanho este número de pessoas que
está nela exatamente obrigado a deixar
uma música pra mim é inspiradora e acho
que é importante votar naquilo que vimos
por cento no último treino
obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]
[Música]